>> All right. Now, you might get a misleading impression
from what I just presented there, because I did this
sort of odd trick that's not really very kosher. Specifically,
when I gave the example of a teacher asking questions
to to lead the learner to a particular hypothesis, I
allowed the teacher to ask any possible question in the
universe of possible questions. Right, so the teacher could construct
a question, and in this particular case, that, that specifically
had a yes answer for the target hypothesis. And a no
answer everywhere else. And that just simply doesn't happen in any
realistic learning questions. So we need to think a little bit
more about the question of what happens when the teacher is
constrained with respect to the kinds of queries that it can
suggest. So I'm going to, I'm going to set up classic computational learning
theory hypothesis class, and we'll go through some examples about what
happens when the teacher's constrained in this way. So let's imagine that
our input space is basically k-bit inputs,
so x1 through xk, and the hypothesis class
[INAUDIBLE] and literals or their negation. So here's
a, here's a concrete example. Here's a hypothesis
that is in this set. X1 and x3 and not x5. We're going to connect together
some of these variables, not necessarily all of
them. And some of them can be negated.
And, it's all the connectors have to be ands. All right, so Charles, let's make
sure that that you understand this. So
let's let's look at, some inputs. Alright. So
let's say our input is this. X1 is 0. x2 is 1. x3 is 0.
x4 is 1. x5 is 1. What is this formula going to evaluate in this case?
>> Okay so, a 0 is false and 1 is true I assume, because,
that's what we do in these things. X2 and x4 don't matter. I just
have to look at x1, x3, and x5. So, x1 had
better be true, and it isn't, so I already know the answer.
>> It's false. Very good. All right, let's let's try a couple more of these.
>> Okay. So, I would do the same thing I did
before. I would look at x1, x3, and x5. So in
this case, x1, cleverly, I've noticed this 1 so, that doesn't
give me the answer right away because you're an evil teacher.
x3 is also 1 but x5 is 1, and according to
the hypothesis it has to be 0 for this to be true,
so 0. I can do the same kind of thing for the
third line, so x1 is true like it needs to be, but
x3 is false instead of being true so also 0. And
then in the bottom, let's see. X1 is true, which it needs
to be. X3 is true, which it needs to be, and X5
is false, which it needs to be, so the output is 1.
>> Very good.
>> All right. I got it.